each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
we're honored today to have Nathan Eagle
visiting us and sharing some very
exciting work and exciting data
collection and analysis going on that
he's leading up nathan is a research
scientist at MIT and a postdoctoral
fellow at the Santa Fe Institute he's
been applying machine learning and graph
theoretic analysis graph analysis to
understanding from from massive data
sets particularly mobile phone and
landline phone communications data
insights about human behavior and in
related phenomena for example disease
processes he's been getting into these
days Nathan was a fulbright scholar in
2006 where he I guess I went off to
Kenya Ethiopia and spent time working in
the mobile phone space in fact yet
developing educational curricula had a
program mobile phones that he is now
being taught widely throughout Africa he
did his bachelor's and master's of
Stanford his PhD at MIT and he's working
on founding a kind of a new area of work
we've been referring to as a ID
artificial intelligence learning and
reasoning for development kind of sub
field and an active subfield pie when
we're exciting subfields of I c4d
information communication technology is
the ict4d vision technology for
development so with that we'll hear from
Nathan today but investigation of
complex social systems from
communication data from hundreds to
thousands to millions and soon to
billions of nodes and their links
amongst one another thanks
thanks Eric um so it's a it's a pleasure
being here maybe a little bit more
background about kind of where I'm
coming from so I was so I joined this
the you know sandy Pentland the wearable
computing group with with sumit best
suen and others back in 2001 and and and
back then in a wearable computer
computing really meant you know
strapping computer literally to your
back and occasionally you'd see guys
with head-mounted displays on their
heads and they would they be walking
around of MIT or Boston capturing really
interesting data about themselves and
about their environment but sometimes
much the amusement of the other people
who are watching them walk around MIT in
Boston and and so I was you know they're
there was some there was a lessor
trajectory where I would be basically
strapping a computer to myself and and
and collecting similar types of data but
this was 2001 2002 and this is kind of
converged when Nokia launched their
first mainstream programmable phone and
so instead of going down the tradition
that wearable computing route it started
hacking on phones and and I've been
basically programming phones ever since
finished up my PhD and and had had
started a small company that essentially
connected socially awkward singles in
Manhattan together based on their mobile
phones and I felt like there's something
more like I really wanted to do is build
an application that had a massive impact
and that this impact just wasn't
happening in the state served Finland or
a career for that matter but in
2005-2006 things were really kicking off
in Africa and so so I was lucky enough
to get a a research scientist position
at MIT but instead of having my office
in Boston I lived in a small village out
on the coast of Kenya village called
Khalifa and and there i did a variety of
different things that eric alluded to
you know starting this kind of mobile
film program in curriculum originally at
the University of Nairobi but it's now
being taught in in Ted sub-saharan
African countries and literally
thousands
of African computer scientists have gone
through this program and learn how to
program phones which is resulted in
hundreds of applications designed
specifically for the African market and
quite a few startups based in Nairobi
and addis ababa and elsewhere and once
that startup is my own it's a company
based in Nairobi called text eagle and
enables enables mobile phone subscribers
to earn small amounts of money on their
phone by completing simple tasks for
corporations who pay their pay them
either an air time or m-pesa which is
the local mobile money this was just
really kind of a pipe dream this time
last year but it's now it's now a
working product across East Africa and
the reason why it happened so quickly is
because I've got fairly strong
connections with well literally every
mobile phone operator in East Africa and
dozens around the world and so those
relationships are going to be what
enable it what enables a lot of the
analysis you see if the latter half of
this of this talk when I'm talking about
scaling to millions and tens of millions
and and soon I hope to have a data set
that involves over a billion people by
this time next year so that's that's a
little bit about about Who I am and now
I'm going to kind of talk now a little
kind of overview of what this talk is
going to go into and it's going to be on
scales of magnitude so so we're going to
start off with what I did my doctoral
research where we studied a hundred
people and we're able to start inferring
the social relationships between people
based on behavioral data and then I'm
going to talk about how that that study
scaled to 2,000 people we did the same
thing but but now this is a thousand
people working in two office buildings
in Helsinki from a thousand people i'll
talk about a data set that that we have
collected with a company immi where
there's this is now 10,000 random sample
people across America or again it's the
same type of uber spyware that's
installed on their phone that I'll go
into detail about from from 10,000 to a
hundred thousand criminals in
Philadelphia and talking about things
like whether or not a crime wave exists
and if a crime wave does exist can we
quantify it in terms of its magnitude in
its speed
is this is what happens if you if you do
it google image search for for criminal
that the other image shows is Bill Gates
and his his photo yeah from a hundred
thousand criminal so I'm going to
talking about the million mobile phone
subscribers in Rwanda and the questions
that we're addressing there are things
like how does this urbanization affect
people's social support groups and and
and the dynamics of things like slums as
Eric alluded to looking at disease and
patterns of disease and see if we can
start seeing is their kind of a
behavioral signature associated with an
outbreak of disease in a particular
region that gets reflected in the CDR
the call data records from 1,000,000 I'm
going to go to the 10 million mobile
phone subscribers in Kenya and and this
is particular data set that's I find
fascinating because it's not just
communication anymore and it's not just
people's movements but now in Kenya
people can send and receive money on
their on their phones and so we now have
this flow of of actually economic
resources throughout the country that
thumb that is that's fascinating to
study from the 10 million kenyans we're
going to go into a hundred million
people in the UK and this is now in
collaboration with British Telecom and
the the civil service in the UK or we're
coupling just about every phone call
made in the country both landline and
mobile with things like socioeconomic
status data access to healthcare
education levels average income and
trying to figure out basically trying to
establish causality like are their
signatures associated with wealth that
are that are indicative again within the
within the call data records and then
lastly you know what does it mean when
we start comparing this data across
cultures across continents what kind of
new research questions can can be
addressed when when n gets inevitably to
to the the level of billions which which
it will in the very near future okay so
that's that's that's kind of an outline
of the talk for people who are familiar
with social network analysis these two
graphs that one in particular should be
should be fairly should be you know
fairly familiar
these are the graph on the top is was
collected back in the 30s by two guys
Roethlisberger and Dixon and and this is
a graph where these are social networks
so the nodes are people and you have an
edge in this case on the top graph if if
you were seen playing cards with the
with another person in this particular
electric company which is being studied
and so so that's that's 11 social
network and this is a social network
that was recorded maybe 40 years later
back in the 70s by and this is the
famous or infamous really zachary karate
club data and and there's been a lot of
people you know a lot of my friends and
peers and people who are you know much
smarter than i am who have dedicated a
large fraction of their lives to
studying this particular graph the
zachary karate club data has been in
literally hundreds of physics journals
where people are trying to look at graph
segmentation trying to trying to pull
out community structure and and so while
so social network analysis is kind of
has veered into has beard well beyond so
Social Sciences to statisticians to to
physicists and yet generally when you
typically when you read these papers
they're really only for kind of the the
papers are have algorithms that are only
applicable for small and Static graphs
despite the fact that we are now
inundated with with behavioral data
that's many orders of magnitude larger
than these types of graphs originally
from the internet but now just from
everyday life and so the a lot of the
projects that I'm going to be over
viewing our come from come from problems
you know they come from people who need
help and those people are you know
anyone from the police chief in
Philadelphia urban planners in Kigali
epidemiologist in Kenya the civil
service in the UK all these these these
individuals are practitioners who
suddenly found themselves in and dated
with data and they're looking to the
academic community for help and are
understandably a little bit confused why
there's so many
brilliant people focused on on a
particular crowded Club from over 30
years ago when in reality there's you
know the data that that we have you know
the data that these guys have is is just
much richer and much my opinion more
interesting but but the problem is it's
not small it's not static it's not
computationally tractable and so
fundamentally we need a new set of tools
to deal with with data that that that
we're currently well that we currently
have today things like betweenness
centrality you know these are metrics
that that well these are fairly
interesting and sophisticated metrics
that that can characterize for in
centrality for example how many Shores
pasco between a you know through a
single node but something like
betweenness centrality is more or less
intractable for any of the type of data
that I I work with and so so what I'm
trying to push for is like come up with
these types of analogs that can that can
do better at analyzing what we what we
have and what we need so the real focus
here is is going to be shifting from
like just thinking about theory and
thinking about you know building a
generative model that can mimic a
particular degree distribution and going
towards really focusing on outcomes so
trying to understand what is it the
process that we that we that we want to
get a better handle on and outcomes of
interest for me are things like disease
they're things like traffic jams there's
things like access to health care and
all these these outcomes of interest are
our basically can be informed by
conditioned on this the tetteh scale
data that we currently have but there's
it is fundamentally two different
philosophies I'm coming at it from the
outcomes perspective rather than looking
at the data for the data sake and that's
that's that's how I at least try to
differentiate some of this particular
work and and I mean and also I don't
want to be misunderstood I mean a lot of
the results here do come from
collaborations as a long series of
collaborations with academics ranging
from social scientists to particle
physicists and where we do try to
validate theory and come up with
better theory about the dynamics of of
complex social systems but for me I i
think the harder question here really is
you know once you've got all this data
and once you fit a particular
distribution how can we start using this
data to improve people's lives like how
can we make the Society of that wherever
this data is coming from how can we make
that society better and that's and
that's kind of going to be an underlying
theme in a lot of the the work that I
may be talking about so with that is a
long-winded introduction let me start on
the first order of magnitude here but
this is N equals a hundred these are
individuals who are subjects in this
original study where we gave out phones
that had more or less uber spyware on it
it started on boot it was invisible to
the end user and it literally logged
everything log communication log
proximity log location and and what you
can do with this type of data is is some
fairly well interesting human modeling
so you know given the fact that subject
104 is is on their way to Central Square
and it's 3 p.m. on a tuesday can we
predict where this person is going to
have dinner can we predict where this
person is going to who's the who this
person is going to have dinner with you
know given the proximity patterns of s
22 and s 18 if they're if they're
approximate by the coffee machine at the
media lab every Tuesday afternoon that
corresponds to one type of relationship
but if their approximate on downtown
Boston late on Saturday night at three
in the morning every single Saturday
night it's a very different type of
relationship and then lastly looking at
the aggregate behavior you can start
seeing things like the onset of for
example MIT finals week by people moving
faster or we were capturing a data when
the red sox won the world series for the
first time and then suddenly all the
models broke everyone became
unpredictable and what happened was the
majority of the subjects went into
downtown boston and there's a big rally
down there and the urban planners they
were interested in looking at how people
just dispersed from that particular
gathering point how many people took the
subway how many people walked over the
bridge how many people rode their bikes
with this type of data we can start
answering questions about how people
utilize urban infrastructure and so
that's that's kind of a bit of a broad
overview of this
type of data set there's a question you
said the spider was invisible so just
this is a general question for ya it's a
private question the subjects know there
was subject oh yeah I mean so I've to do
this study I mean I can I mean we can
tell who's sleeping with whom right
right i mean so so there's this there's
a massive amount of intrusion in terms
of privacy you would never be able to do
this at least in an academic context
without having them signing a massive
consent form absolutely right if some
issue if they know that you'll be
noticed it behave like that was it for
that's that people I mean that and I was
I was concerned about that as well and
if you if you saw the first week of
behavior it does deviate significantly
from from the rest of behavior but what
you can see is that people basically
kind of slip into a rout like basically
follow routine whether or not that's a
routine that's that's influenced by the
fact that they know that they have just
spyware on their phones it might very
well might be but I think that it's that
that first week where they got nervous
and then they forget about it to see if
that their first week scales do like
different like a bit as n increases that
does that number change right I think it
really depends on a demographic right so
so in the next data set I'm going
talking about it's these are individuals
who work for a large finish cell phone
manufacturer and and these guys like
like they're so used to be participating
in these types of studies where I like I
think that would be even less but uh but
the end of the day it's it's hard to
answer that question for obvious reasons
one of the things that I've been trying
to push with with very minimal success
is this idea of characterizing an
individual or demographic with this
notion of entropy so this idea of how
much structure is in their behavior how
much information how much randomness so
this idea of information entropy is how
much information is in a particular you
know time series in this case so this is
an example of an individual who's a low
entropy person meaning so this is a this
is the whites parts is hit as him at
home
he's at work and then he's back home
again his stress his day-to-day
structures is dictated by dropping off
his kids and picking them up to and from
from school whereas this was an
individual who actually was my office
mate at the time who's a grad student
much he's just as likely to be in the
office at 3am as 3pm like so you'd have
to really squint to see much structure
here so high entropy low entropy and it
should be pretty obvious then that like
when we're starting to parameterize
individuals in terms of their behavior
in terms of predicting what they're
going to do next we can do we can do a
lot better on the low entropy people
like you can you can see the patterns
you can figure out you can get a pretty
good guess when he's going to show up to
work the next day whereas the higher
entropy it's it's a bit trickier and
then you can start characterizing
demographics this way too so we care we
know we gave out phones to these 18 year
olds who just arrived on campus you know
the business school students admin staff
and it's you know and again it's not
particularly surprising but it's it's
the freshman that are the most entropic
we also had well one other subject that
that I ended up throwing out and I'll
talk about him a little bit more in
detail later but he was he was off the
charts in terms of entropy he was what
well beyond well beyond 50 and he was
Marvin Minsky and I like basically I
threw him out because like he was he was
messing up everything and I figured that
he would be he was such an outlier that
didn't matter I'll talk a little bit
later about how we were discovering
people these individuals across
different demographics who are extremely
hot very entropic and and it makes me
kind of reconsider throwing him out of
the data set location
could be
visits place of type X within just
reading t yeah exact same place yeah
we're going to vote with it within a
larger time horizon but if I think
different strengths I need to find
sameness it like a different sport kinds
of analysis there's that's totally true
and and in this case this is this is
broken down on on hourly windows and
placed in this context is things like
home work elsewhere that sort of thing
but depending on how you structure it
you can get I'm sure radically different
entropy scores but the point originally
was just simply get a single metric and
try to quantify how much structure is in
someone's life and then once you do that
one of the things that you can start you
can start doing is trying to model a
particular you know every single day and
in this case what we're doing is you can
think of every day in a subjects life as
a single point in a really high
dimensional space right and and the
point one of the issues is that we don't
live lot our lives as random number
generators but rather these these points
are so they're not randomly distributed
through that high dimensional space but
they're clustered and so if you just do
a simple dimensionality reduction on
this you can actually start pulling out
what the what the the principal
components are we calling these eigen
behaviors because my advisor at the time
you know created this I I can face
literature and so and so this is using
it more or less like the identical
technique but trying to quantify these
salient behaviors associated with
individuals lives and you you computed
so the PCA was on and you did
individuals yep so it seemed yeah so you
can basically we get a matrix of these
of these this time series and sis we're
just taking taking the eigen
decomposition of
ference matrix left so you're doing a
separate decomposition perfect person
yes correct said and this in this and
then two slides later I'll show we
change that yeah but you know I just
wanted this is something that kind of
pulls out some obvious things where you
can start looking at how many eigen
behaviors you need how many of these
vectors do you need to recreate
someone's day and so for low entropy low
entropy subjects you don't need very
many whereas in higher higher entropy
subjects you do to get the same type of
accuracy but then just assume it's point
so originally this was just for a single
you know each day was a particular point
but now you could start characterizing
individuals as a single point in a very
high dimensional space and and then
characterized demographics so this is no
this is for kind of a toy example but
you can this case what we're doing is
trying to quantify the sloan business
school behavior space so you know
collapsing all the business school
students down and trying to quantify
their their their behavior on it in this
case a to do so with two vectors and
then what we would do is we would just
try to figure out whether or not
someone's a business will student by
measuring the Euclidean distance between
that space and and where they lie and we
got something like over ninety percent
accuracy in terms of differentiating
business school students alright so
that's so that's looking at kind of in
on an individual level and now i'm going
to talk about dyads so pairs of people
it's this is a graph here of basically
proximity over the course of a day and
this is the friendship graph so the
research challenge is trying to figure
out how do you win Oh down the edges in
this particular graph to get at what the
underlying friendship graph is and and
i'll be kind of approaching this problem
from a lot of angles whether this is you
know proximity in this case via
bluetooth or the operators have a lot of
communication data so trying to figure
out because also so what the operators
have is this massive communication graph
and what they want to get at is a social
network so trying to look at a social
network through the lens of proximity or
through the lens of communication and
get at what the underlying relationships
are is an important question what we've
been able to get though
as much richer data than just operators
have I mean we have we can think about a
graph that has multi-dimensional edges
you know one type of edge could be
things like whether you're proximate on
Saturday nights another type of edge
could be our approximate at that
person's house another edge would be
communication so we've got this this
graph the social network with lots of
different types of edges and the
challenge here is trying to infer what
are where are the friends can we can we
infer the topology of the friendship
graph based on all these higher
dimensional edges and it turns out you
can pretty trivially I mean this is a my
collaborator likes to call this the
relationship EKG I don't there's
probably a better name for it but I
haven't come up with it but this this is
probability of proximity at MIT in this
case and then off campus and and there's
three different relationship types right
there's if I'm friends with Mike if I
say in France to mike and mike says
these friends with me that's reciprocal
that's green if I say in French with
Mike but Mike says he's not friends with
me that's that's an asymmetric
relationship and then of course there's
the the symmetric non friends and what
we're finding is that there's a
symmetric friendships are generally when
that when you're really proximate a lot
at work meaning if you're working with
Mike a lot you may assume that you guys
are friends but but you know Mike may
not think that you are but if you if you
look at approximately on Saturday nights
for example you get a much more you know
it's it's you know if your approximate
Saturday nights off campus especially
you're much more likely to be friends
and so we can get something like a
ninety-six percent accuracy in terms of
inferring the edges of the the
friendship network but we can do a
little bit I think what we can do a
little bit better because we want the
survey traditionally was just you know
Mark off the people you're friends with
yes or no what we can recreate is an
actual weight associated with the
relationship or that weight is
characterized by you know how much time
you spent having dinner with that person
at that person's house having lunch
traveling with the person communicating
over the phone etc and so I think we can
get a much kind of richer depiction of
what the true relationship is and and
what's nice about I mean this is this is
going to be coming out in pnas I
in a month and a half what's what's nice
about this particular technique is that
we're able to kind of scale traditional
social social network analysis to a much
larger group of people potentially
meaning like so we had to kind of get
ground truth and so we had to have
people go through a survey where they
read all 100 100 names off and had to
check the names that they are friends
with that obviously just won't scale as
you want to increase your sample size
like they're not going to you're not
going to be able to get people to do
that for a thousand people or 10,000
people or the 100 million people that
I'll be talking about the end and so you
need another system to be able to kind
of quantify what the social network is
without having to deal with these types
of service all right so now from 1-100
MIT students we're going to 1,000
individuals who are living in Helsinki
and what we've done here is we basically
put the same goober spyware on on all of
their phones and what we did one more
really obnoxious thing every 20 calls
they make we have a little survey that
pops up and asks them to label the
relationship is this person a friend is
this person an office worker
acquaintance a colleague no relationship
this is the won't disclose pattern so
this is just the temporal pattern like
the distal end portal distribution of
win individuals make calls to what type
of relationship and so we don't we not
only have the temporal but we also have
the location where those calls were made
yeah this is making calls yeah we had
the survey only go when when you when
you make a call but again this is kind
of leads us into this this this problem
that the operators have right where
they've got all this communication data
and they really want to get at
relationship and the operators have come
up with sneaky ways of getting it right
they've you've heard of like the
friends-and-family plan or the fav five
or whatever the t-mobile is pushing like
they're trying to get there trying to
get access to this type of data from you
and what we're trying to do is build a
little classifier to see if there are
kind of discrete signatures associated
with these types of relationships so
from a thousand fins now this is at
thousand random sampled individuals
across America and the real key
component here is this is random sample
so this is through a collaboration with
immi what I'm I did was did that
original reality mining sub study so
that uber spyware on people's phones but
they used one additional sensor that I
wasn't allowed to use due to kuya
straints as well as the fact that I
don't think anyone would sign up for it
or else I didn't at the time and that
sensor is the microphone so they're
turning the microphone on on these
phones for ten seconds every minute and
recording the ambient audio pushing it
back to a server so you guys have you
guys heard of that she isn't like
there's these companies where you hold
up the phone to the radio and you get a
text message back about what the songs
being placed the guys started that
company came out he does PhD I think
finished it about ten years ago and
started a couple a couple companies that
were basically doing this acoustic
matching you know both in Europe and and
here in the States this is his latest
company and he's found that this and I
think they just finished closing a
fifty-million-dollar around from draper
Nielsen is trying to hostile acquire
them like they're they're a hot
commodity and the reason why there are
hot commodities because his algorithm
not only lets you figure out what songs
being played but what advertising you're
being exposed to and so you can actually
get a much better sense of whether we
know what media people are consuming
what TV show you're watching what what
movie you're watching what radio station
you're listening to in the car and
what's the the really cool thing I think
well one of the really cool things is
that they're able to show kind of
marketing efficacy so if you've watched
the the co-branded Burger King simpsons
ad you're actually much more likely to
go into the simpsons movie like they can
actually they can they can make these
types of claims now and they can make
them because this is 10,000 randomly
sampled individuals and one of the major
critiques with the earlier work that
I've talked about is that ok so you've
parameterised the lives of 100 MIT
students so what right like how does
that scale to the population at large
suddenly we're able to start talking now
about well basically about the patterns
of you know much more generalizable
patterns about demographic
so not just MIT freshman but we can we
can say now that the most entropic group
that we found in these hundred thousand
people turn out to be women under 30 who
are making more than sixty thousand
dollars in our college educated like you
know these are these are now claims that
we can make because we have a random
sample so from 10,000 random sample of
individuals across America this is now a
hundred thousand criminals now so a red
car corresponds to a carjacking the
little circle corresponds to a graffiti
event the martini glass is public
drunkenness them let's see the RX symbol
is a drug bust so what we're trying to
do here the research question is you
know is crime contagious is there such a
thing as as a crime wave and originally
when I wrote a little script that would
plot these things as a time series I was
hoping to start seeing kind of you know
spread over over something like a
lattice but it's it's clearly a bit more
noisy than than anticipated and and so
that's a project going on with with a
student of mine and an epidemiologist
from upenn trying to trying to get it
answering this question but there's been
other in the past a lot of literature on
things like is obesity contagious is
smoking contagious I'm using a similar
technique actually in the I think of the
New England Journal Medicine recently
there's a paper where they showed that
height was contagious and acne was
contagious so you have to be really
careful when you're when you're talking
about contagion over a social network
when there's when there's things as home
awfully this idea of birds of a feather
flocking together and so disambiguating
like what is some awfully and what is an
actual contagion well for me it turned
out it was a lot harder problem than I
anticipated
so anyways that's so that's my that's
that's my hundred thousand and and now
I'm going to launch into in to see dr so
CDR stands for call data records it's
it's the data that mobile operators
capture about their their subscribers
and just so make sure that everyone's on
the same page this data is it's it's far
richer than just a communication graph I
mean well we've got things like the
collar and the receiver we've got the
time the duration of the call the cell
tower that's associated with the call
and certain this state in this data set
we've got four years of data and and
this is data from the the only
telecommunication company in the country
so this is represents every phone call
made in the country over over four years
and so what that enables you to do is
answer or ask some really interesting
questions about you know how society in
general is evolving over time we've got
things like me to you airtime transfer
so you can actually send and receive
airtime on on these handsets and that's
that's being done on average about four
times a month per subscriber they've got
individual so not only do you have kind
of these multi-dimensional edges where
edges could be a text sending a text
message making a phone call sending
airtime but you've also got a bunch of
attributes for the notes you know we
know what phones people are using we
know what region they're calling we know
scratchcard denomination Eric and I were
talking about this earlier today so all
these markets or at least most of the
markets that I am involved in are
generally prepaid so that most of the
world has prepaid markets where you buy
a scratch card at you know you and you
can buy scratch cards all over Rwanda in
most most places on earth now where for
airtime and so you can buy in Rhonda's
case you could buy 25 cent 25 cents
worth airtime all the way up to cards
that have a $25 denomination and so what
we've been doing is looking at how this
denomination is a proxy for
socioeconomic status and looking at
basically how you like using that to to
couple that with
things like the census data that we have
from firma Wanda and an understanding
what what the what the distribution of
wealth is in the country and how these
calling patterns are reflective of that
the other thing I wanted to focus on
before I move forward is the fact as the
privacy implications again right so
these are individuals now who did not
sign a consent form and and originally I
thought this was going to be a real
challenge to get it through coup ease
which is the IRB at MIT but there's
there's two things that make this make
mated a lot easier one thing was that
these way I have no phone numbers I have
anonymized IDs that are associated with
a sim card and secondly I'm not doing
any data collection this data already
exists and sitting on a server actually
sitting on a bunch of servers and
underground in Kigali at the moment so
so with those two caveats this type of
research becomes viable in an academic
sense so one of the students who is
working with me at SFI right now is is
is writing his thesis what was getting
distracted in a lot of projects but his
thesis was how the structure of society
and the stability of society how looking
at this data over a long period of time
trying to identify clicks that form and
clicks that that basically that the
dissolve are there particular
characteristics of groups of people that
are correlated with the stability of
their relationships like so can we
identify relationships that are going to
be persistent can we identify groups of
people that are going to basically stay
a group for a long period of time where
a group is defined as individuals who
communicate a lot with each other so
that's that's way we've made less
progress on that than not that I've
wanted to but it was actually was
inspired by a nature paper lots of our
boss she wrote maybe three or four years
ago or he was basically asking the
similar types of questions but getting
getting at it at a different way he was
using data I think from from on the
order of about a year but now we've got
we've got with four years of data and
and literally every every phone every
phone call in the country I think
can do we can we can do a pretty good
job at this so so when when we started
well when the day club when the data
started back in january 2005 it was two
hundred thousand people in rwanda had
cell phones would by the time the data
ended it was 1.4 million which was about
fifteen percent of the of the country at
the moment and that number is I mean
Africa is the fastest growing mobile
phone market in the world that number is
is is rising almost exponentially which
is which is exciting and you know I
would think it was much higher
percentage of both found unit
thank you if you we have so if you look
at number of phones per household it's
it's well over fifty percent alright so
one of the reasons why I kind of kept
keep focusing on the fact that this is
every phone call in the country is that
you know in previous work in laws laws
laws laws as well like they've been
working with operators that have less
than one hundred percent market share
generally less than thirty percent
market share and so we have a paper now
basically showing how what the
implications are when you're having that
kind of sampling so if you're if you
have all the data from a single operator
and that operator has twenty percent
market share what it turns out is you
only have four percent of the edges and
in less than a percent of the triangles
and so when you start wanting to kind of
build something that diffuses over that
graph you get radically different
dynamics then if you had the full graph
and and soon a layman over at in barber
she's lab he's been a big advocate of
this the fact that we need to get away
from this idea of discrete community
structure you know when people talk
about community structure and graphs
generally we assume that a node can only
belong to one community but that's I
mean that's kind of it seems a bit silly
when you think about it if you think
about your own social network you're
affiliated with you know your college
you're college community and then your
Microsoft community and move your high
school community you're family community
so we've got a lot of different
communities but it turns out if your
symp sample social network down to
something like twenty percent you do get
this kind of discrete community topology
but as you increase your sample size you
get overlapping communities you get a
densification of the graph and and so
that's kind of what we're showing here
is that you know the number of
memberships increase as you increase
sample size but we're able to do is
recreate all of this all of the previous
results that have been you know looking
at processes that diffuse over a social
network that has been previously
published at least when that when those
use when those authors were looking at
twenty percent graph and we could
recreate those dynamics when we sampled
are great
twenty percent but then as we increase
the sampling size those dynamics they
changed quite a bit and so that's so
we've got a paper now and Submission on
on talking about how those dynamics
change and the fact that when we when
you want to think about constraining an
epidemic initially we've we focus on on
looking at the super spreaders which are
generally the hubs but what we found is
that actually membership for a lot for
you know a large number of communities
is four times more important than degree
meaning it's more important to know how
many memberships you have with these
different communities than simply
whether the fact that you've got a high
degree all right so that's how something
spreads of spreads them for gravity okay
in this case you could think about it as
information I mean right now we just
used a simple SI model so susceptible
infected model and this is bad this this
shouldn't be confused with disease per
se but this is this is what you know
people have been using social social
graphs to as a proxy for how disease
would diffuse
the details these people are studied in
submission what are you doing used to be
saying giving this graph somehow I like
I could I go for one know what we do is
we look at the how many people you
ultimately infect so so we run the
simulation thousands of times we take
one individual out of the 1.4 million we
infect them and then and then we watch
this thing spread over time and over a
long period of time standard contagion
model and applying the rat usually it's
immensely park as Jason see or a
probability pages in this with or
without the Arkham place yes okay so
that's so that and that's basically just
talking about the the implications of
sampling um is allow for a jump you have
to yeah you can't you you have to be
connected in order to and yeah to
disseminate something in that case I'll
have you collected you have to yeah you
have you have to have an edge what can
imagine
noisy models where you with much greater
difficulty types of leading ambiance
without the art for the that's tricky
always noisy but when York is there no
diverging yeah you could be there's all
sorts of I mean what we wanted to do is
do the absolute dead simplest model just
to show the effective of membership
versus degree but as you increase the
level of sophistication you increase the
realism but then then you add a bunch of
other things that may make your point
less clear in this case this is this is
now another or potentially clearer but
with more variables so more more
susceptible to getting shot down by
reviewers so another another study that
we wanted to order the question we
wanted to ask was about the the effect
of cities and in this case this is okay
so i should i should spend a little bit
of time explaining this graph this is a
these are all individuals who move from
a rural area into the capital and they
move at 0 so they're spending the time
in the rural area here and then they and
then they move to the capital and then
the back movers the individuals that end
up moving back are characterized by the
solid line and so you can start seeing
so this is this is the degree this is
their degree so this is a number of
people that they call in the rural area
and as they move to the capital it goes
down but then the back movers they move
back after about six months and then
establish the same rural degree where
and the same kind of goes for this is
their capital degree so that goes up
when they move their but then they never
they never really fully integrate and
then move back and then it goes so that
it goes low again whereas the people who
permanently move as this dashed line
here so moving from a rural region to a
capital this is your capital degree so
it's it's more or less kind of static
and then it jumps and it keeps just kind
of going up so the idea here is you know
how does how does cities affect
individuals 11 notion is this this
hypothesis called differential selection
meaning that you you behave differently
you know individuals in the rural area
who are behaving like an urban person
the more they behave like that urban
person the more they kind of get pulled
into the capital
so that is diff that's kind of a theory
of differential selection they're
different from their home environment
and that's what's driving them to move
and you can actually see you know the
individuals who do who do move are
different this is kind of the the
average rural degree and the people who
do move I have a lower kind of have less
integration have less contacts within
that rural area you're described as the
way they communicate with each other
this is this is a purely looking at the
degree so this is this is I mean I guess
which is kind of a proxy for behavior
but this is the number of people these
individuals called both in their home
environment I don't need to try to divvy
those up into sort of rural and urban
scruffy if you've got communication
pattern your rural but you have
communication madam it's closer to the
urban then you then you're more likely
to leave and that's and that is kind of
the theory of differential selection the
other theory that's kind of you know has
been in the literature for decades is
this behavioral adaptation so meaning
you you know you move to the city and
suddenly then you behave more like an
individual who you know who is in a city
and so what we're what we're trying to
do is kind of figure out how much is
differential selection how much is
behavioral adaptation and it's still
very much a work in progress but we're
seeing clear signs of both and then the
other thing that has we're making
progress on but I think we're not quite
there yet is this idea of integration so
looking at how long does it take for
individuals to integrate into these
different communities both these urban
communities and these rural communities
and and we're finding that it's a lot
easier for people to integrate into an
urban environment than the rural
environment and then there's there's fun
other things about rural environments
where as you know you may have lesser
degree but the tie strength is much
greater you know people in rural areas
they don't have as many contacts but
their relationships are stronger as
measured by call volume so there's
there's some interesting dynamics going
on urban versus rural and I've got
another student at SFI now who's working
on kind of building a generative model
for these these urban the urban growth
and specifically she's looking at kabira
which is the largest slum in the world
so just outside of Nairobi and what
we're able to do
is look at how this slum is changing
over time we're inferring tribe by
looking at what regions of Kenya
individuals living in this area are
calling and you can start seeing the
dynamics of how a kind of turnover of
these different tribes moving in and out
of these neighborhoods and the hope pair
is that we can start parameterizing this
in a way that we can quantify how that
how the slum is growing over time and
with what type of inhabitants and and
this is important for people doing urban
planning I mean these guys they need to
figure out where to put the next
latrines where to put the next pieces of
infrastructure where's the slum going to
go next in these slums in these
developing world countries are very
organic their ad hoc they grow in kind
of a very much an unsupervised manner
but I think they say and this is very
much work in progress but I think that
it is looking like they're they have
particular patterns in their dynamics
that can be quantified and if they can
be quantified we can get some insight
into really what's going on this is
coming from yeah Rwanda in Kenya so
actually this this slum is Kenya which
is 10 million so I jumped ahead but
we're also we're working we're working
with the with the city planners in
Kigali he golly has their own sense of
slums but it's not the world's biggest
slum so we're basically applying these
models but but we're using cubera right
now as well so I I hate I hate the term
universal law of human anything but uh
but this is this is kind of well this
was the name of the grant that we got
and so it's now the title of the slide
but the idea is looking at quantifying
how mobility models scale over over
different people from different cultures
and different continents and so what
Marta did earlier last year was
basically parameterised populations
mobility in terms of a radius generation
so it's kind of using a standard gravity
model she's able to find kind of have
the distribution of these radiuses and
what we're doing now is is looking at
what this distribution is across a
variety of different regions both in
America
latin america south america africa
europe and and seeing how you know what
what what holds as as kind of
commonality and what is different across
these these different regions in terms
of diffusion not only do we have so when
we talk about CDR data we not only have
the communication data but we also have
this product adoption so what products
people are adopting over time and
especially in places like kenya like
rwanda like the dominican republic where
there there hasn't been as much mass
marketing simply because people who live
in more rural areas and are less
connected the importance of kind of how
people hear about a product is a you
know the basically comes from your peers
and so what we found and this what's
striking is this holds true both in the
UK as as well as in kenya as well as in
the dr is that if we were going to start
quantifying the probability that an
individual adopts particular product you
know this you have you have a try as you
have three people and be both adopted
you want to know what the probability of
C adopting is it's it's significantly
more so meaning the probability of C
adopting goes up significantly when the
try it is closed when a and B are
friends when am be our friends they
exert more mutual influence over C then
then if they're not connected and and
it's striking how that that result seems
to hold again across across a wide range
of markets and across a wide range of
products this is a this is now kind of
work that's that's veering towards
developmental economics but I think kind
of should scale to a wide range of
events this is the implications of what
happened in an earthquake back in
February two of two thousand eight and
what you're seeing here I mean so thus
over the first thing is well you type in
Rwanda earthquake and you see this
massive spike and you find out that
there's an earthquake in yama shake a
region on februari third and and then
you can start plotting what the telus is
these are the behavior that's coming
from cell towers in this particular
region and on the y-axis this is
outgoing minus incoming calls this the
the net outgoing minus the net incoming
you can see basically the cell towers
were the time series started about here
and you generally have more outgoing
than incoming until that earthquake
happened and then suddenly things change
dramatically and this is this is a plot
that literally we generated about five
days ago so there's no more kind of
analysis beyond what you're seeing but I
think what it points to is an ability to
start ability to do things that Eric and
I have spent the morning talking about
being able to do surveillance whether
it's disease surveillance or our
flooding of trying to detect flooding or
crisis or market collapse you know we
have this data now on on how people are
communicating how people are traveling
how people are sharing our time and and
and the hope is that we can look and go
to this next slide we can start
parameterizing people's reactions to
these these catastrophes and in a way
that we can use it for surveillance you
know is can we do something and I'll
goes to the two that Google you know
that Google Flu Trends paper right so so
I like the analogy that this we could do
something similar with CDR and instead
of people typing in search queries about
about sicknesses we can identify key
behaviors that are indicative of an
outbreak you know signatures that are
associated with people who are getting
sick or who have recently been flooded
or recently been exposed to something
like an earthquake if you have a
question you dust upon the entire saying
if there is a close that affects the
decision-making of the third person have
you applied that theory to the moving
data that you had like who echo effects
who's the influencer and like when
people move from
maybe of the city hi no we haven't I
mean that's good I guess Mexicans have
you been did someone in finding like
something to the effect of who
influences things and social class
that's a very decent station right now
we're just looking at aggregate behavior
we're not trying to pull out individuals
who are who are influencing more than
more than others but but that probably
at some point we will do that I'm and
we're still just trying to get our head
around kind of what the aggregates
looking at doing first and so and so
anyway so there's there's a lot of
there's a lot of there's a lot of
questions that can be addressed whether
it's you know trying to identify so I'm
working with us you're a group of
epidemiologists Imperial and and what
they're trying to do is quantify how
malaria is how mobility affects malaria
so how people's movements around East
Africa change this spread of that
particular disease and and you know and
with Eric we've been talking a lot about
trying to quantify people's reactions to
something like cholera like when there's
a cholera outbreak and there have been
dozens of cholera outbreaks there during
the time period where we're looking at
this data can we start characterizing
how a region responds to something like
that and ideally can we characterize the
onset of a cholera outbreak can we see
the the events that leading up to a
potential disease outbreak we can
quantify that then then we can do some
route some some some real good did your
game
yeah so if you can close the loop if you
can identify when something when a
disaster is about to happen there's
there's a lot of organizations both
governmental and non-governmental that
would be very eager to to to help out
Josh and I so josh is a student at the
at Berkeley he died he just arrived in
Kigali today and we're conducting a
study a phone study where we were kind
of or were surveying people and asking
them a variety of both socio-economic
questions but also about you know what
their livelihood is dependent on and
whether or not they've been involved in
an economic crash of some sort or like
you know been touched that way with the
idea of trying to figure out how
behavior is correlated with things like
market prices alright so now from a
million a million Rwandans we've got
essentially the same data for Kenya now
it's 10 million mobile phone subscribers
in Kenya but we've got an additional
additional edge type instead of just
communication and air time sharing we've
got actually how people are sending and
receiving money across these different
regions it's a product called m-pesa
which is mobile money in Kiswahili and
what m-pesa has enabled is a variety of
really interesting applications that
that lie on top of it so I mentioned
earlier this company text Eagle based in
Nairobi and what it simply does is
enables people to earn small amounts of
money on their phone by completing
really simple tasks for for corporations
who pay them generally in air time or
m-pesa tasks are things like
transcription translation image tagging
surveys we've got well I mean right now
we've got something like 15 million
subscribers who now have phones that
they were they can start earning money
and and the question is coming up with
enough tasks to meet the demand and we
soft launched in February and with a
series of translation tasks and we had
to we had the
shut the service down after after
something like six hours because we ran
out of kakuyu and lua tasks we we
introduced the service to some taxicab
drivers and some high school students
and and just within within hours we had
thousands of users like there's a huge
demand for being able to start making
money on your phone by completing work
and it's now it's just a question of
figuring out how to get enough tasks and
I mean it's pretty exciting I mean I NSO
if people in this room have an idea
about how how crowdsourcing can you know
what particular paid tasks that can be
can be done on them on a handset and
it's important that think that these are
these are not kind of smartphones this
is a handset from the handset that you
had ten years ago so so we've been
initially we deployed via SMS but now
we've gone to ussd which is um well I
mean so SMS is to us SD what what email
is to tell me so ussd is this kind of
persistent session spaced gsm protocol
that is that is appropriate that works
on literally every single one of the
four billion gsm phones on the planet
today so it's a fantastic opportunity I
think it's a great protocol but the
problem with at us SD is that you have
to be an operator in order to deploy a
ussd service and so this is done very
very you know this is basically done
in-house with these operators so that's
0 and then I kind of put mechanism
design so this is this is an example of
trying to figure out what the kind of
incentive and reward structure should be
so that that you can get this work done
and when we initially launched I think
we were we were probably paying people
too much people were earning upwards of
three dollars an hour and and that was
that I think you know when we when we
redo this again I think really what
we're going to try to do is cap how much
you the daily the daily amount you can
earn is to maybe a dollar or even less
so that we get a wider selection of
people who are completing these tasks so
from that those you know ten million
East Africans this is now 100 million
individuals in the UK this is a graph
actually a
it's a social network now 250 million
unique phone numbers 12 billion edges
and we've got things like the nodes are
characterized by region by product
adoption and the edges have have a time
and duration associated with them this
is this represents virtually every
mobile every phone every landline phone
call in about eighty percent of the
mobile phones for the month of August of
2005 so it's uh it's it's a very large
graph and I'm at the Santa Fe Institute
now and so one of the one of the job
requirements is just show straight lines
on log log plots and this is a
particularly good straight line this
this shows calls made for in this case
this is August nineteenth 2005 and what
you're seeing is you know ten million
people in the UK made one call yeah 1
million people made ten calls so a
hundred thousand people made a hundred
calls and it just keeps going down and
down and the thing that kind of you know
one of the things that initially gets
gets pointed out is like who are these
people who are making you know a hundred
thousand phone calls in that particular
day and this this seems to be true
across these different data sets are
they like this is it's a true power all
the way out to the tail and these are
clearly not human and actually we have a
little or trying to build a little
classifier that tries to pull out what
you know machine related properties if
so if you behave like a machine we're
not going to count you anymore but this
is the this is the unfiltered an
unfiltered graph and the kind of the
thing that's striking for me I think is
just the fact that out of the behavior
of hundreds of millions of idiosyncratic
individuals every single day it's this
is a straight line but the interesting
thing is that it's the straight line the
slope of the line the exponent of the
power law changes with the day of the
week so you have like a monday tuesday
wednesday thursday friday saturday
sunday monday tuesday wednesday thursday
friday saturday sunday and that's calls
out and then you have a mirrored a
degree you have a mirrored exponent for
calls received so there there's
something fundamental about what's going
on with the dynamics there that's that i
think is interesting we've been doing a
little bit of work of just looking at
how how distance effects probability of
communication so this idea for
pink whaty is this notion the fact that
you're much more likely to be friends
with people who are who are approximate
to you and in what we've done is this is
kind of similar to a pnas paper by david
levin know where he took a livejournal
data set and looked at the probability
that individuals with link based on zip
codes and this is what we've been able
to do is recreate that distribution that
he found for livejournal with with the
UK and it looks like rwanda and the dr
follow a similar distribution as well
communications over we get an additional
study how often do you talk to somebody
given any more on your graph and it goes
up with business goes up with this yes
this thing is you see people Heisey yes
really if it you beautiful people so you
say you're low but yet you're low weight
I said approximately should we should do
that too so so any case we're seeing
similar I mean that's kind of a neat and
that's a neat finding right whether it's
instant messenger data whether this
livejournal data whether it's
communication data from England from the
middle of a village in Rwanda like
getting these sim the same types of
distributions repeatedly across
different types of communication medium
across very different types of
demographics now I think there's
something interesting there but it gets
more interesting once we have that
outcome of interest so so looking at the
outcome of interest for this slide is is
the end the multiple index of
deprivation which is an aggregate score
that's associated with access to
healthcare education levels and average
income this is for the UK and so what
we're what we're doing here is we're
testing the granite vetter hypothesis
the strength of weak ties right so
granovetter many years ago has the kind
of has theorized that it's it's going to
be that / that acquaintance that's going
to get you your next job it's not your
best friend who's going to be able to
kind of push you forward
socio-economically but rather it's it's
these weaker ties and what we've done is
we've looked at diversity so again
diversity now is as well we in this case
this is a Shannon entropy metric but we
saw we've also used Simpson metric for
diversity and it's it's more or less the
same as idea of how much entropy is in
an egocentric graph based on the
geography that they're calling and it's
what's striking is that so socioeconomic
status it's really not that correlated
with its with your degree or your call
volume its meaning it's not the number
of friends you have or how much time you
spend on the phone but rather it's this
diversity score it's whether you have a
you have you have contacts in a wide
range of areas and so that's this is
this is a pretty amazingly strong
correlation especially in the social
sciences where we're explaining more
than half of the variance in a group of
people that numbers 50 million so this
is this is a major result but the
controversy right now is figuring out
what's really driving this because
there's another kind of there's another
theory from Bert about structural holes
and constraints and I could spend a
little bit of detail about talking about
that but basically is essentially it's
just if your friends are friends so if
you have an insular group what Bert
theorized was that that's going to
constrain you that's going to mean that
you have you it's harder for you to
change and that constraint is going to
affect your social economic status
whereas if you a lot of holes in your
system meaning if you got a lot of discs
you know friends in a lot of different
places then then then basically you're
going to do bet you're going to be
better off and so you could see how
there's parallels there with diversity
and so trying to figure out what's
what's really the driving force is is
still an open question but but at the
end of the day we're able to start
validating these types of theories
because we have this this amazing these
amazing data sets and it's not just it's
not just all the communication graph but
it's also that you through the UK civil
service is they've done very detailed
studies about the socioeconomic status
of all these regions in the UK and so
it's really when combining these two
things where we can where we can get
some some interesting results yeah
you're in service little doll that no
basil knees theta more remains in the
best well that would be the ultimate
goal so today no and one of the reasons
is I can't what I can't really advocate
them to do that because what we haven't
done is talked about causality well the
only done is talked about when we talk
about correlation if I can establish
causality then I can actually make a
case to the government saying like look
this is a particular policy you need to
start adopting we need to you to you
know create these longer edge ties
across across the nation and improve
everyone's social economic status I
can't make that case of the government
yet because because I don't know whether
or not which direction it goes my guess
is going both ways right so people who
have hired higher you know have higher
diversity they're going to be exposed to
more opportunities and so that's going
to drive socioeconomic status up but the
wealthy individuals by the nature of
being wealthy will have these longer
ties as well and so trying to figure out
which way causality works is is very
much an open question okay and then I'm
going to wrap it up now I mean with the
with the billions and this would I'm
working with like I said dozens of
mobile phone operators from from around
the world and and it allows us to ask a
variety of really interesting questions
whether it's looking at the dynamics of
relations between nation states and
looking at how culture affects things
disease outbreak warnings etc so so to
wrap it up I mean I've talked about
where N equals 100 I'm starting to infer
the friendship graph based on these
behavioral signatures where when n is a
thousand trying to figure out what kind
of relationships people have friends
office workers colleagues based on their
communication behaved behavior and
equals ten thousand this is the random
sample 10,000 individuals across America
and learning how learning basically what
what random sampling can do for us so
the hundred thousand criminals in philly
trying to figure out whether or not
there is such a thing as a crime wave
and whether or not crime is contagious
to a million people where we're looking
at you know how the effect of
urbanization affects people's support
social net
trying to understand how disease and
disease dynamics interplay with things
like mobility and communication 10
million people is just looking at how
resources there with the network
economic resources and then this
platform text eagle that enables people
to earn money on their phone then 100
million trying to trying to validate for
act believe the first time this theory
of granovetter had about the whether or
not these weak ties really are strong
economically and then now it's into the
billions where it's possible to start
comparing across cultures and across
continents and and it is striking the
similarities that we're initially
finding I mean so it is this study with
Marta it seems like that people in the
Dominican Republic move in similar
patterns to the way people move around
Rwanda which bears striking parallels to
how people move around San Francisco in
LA in Belgium there's particular types
of information that spread over Greater
London with exactly the same dynamics as
it spreads through a village in in Kenya
so we're at a time now where we can
almost well I'm still pushing a little
bit against it but we can almost start
talking about universal laws universal
laws of human behavior but I think kind
of the the the bigger question the fact
that kind of the ultimate open question
here is is really than engineering
question like once we've got all this
data once we've got all these insights
once we built this model of a system how
can we how can we use these insights and
use this data to actively improve
people's lives because I'm as big a fan
of as anyone about plotting the
aggregate behavior of 100 million people
mana on a log-log plot and fitting a
distribution and and then and then
raising up your arms and yelling Eureka
and claiming that you found a new law of
human behavior that's the easy part I
think that the fundamentally the harder
part is trying to figure out a way that
we can use this data to improve the
lives and a better both the lives of the
billions of people who are generating
this data continuously and the societies
in which they live and for that it's
it's no longer the social scientists who
want to be validating theories or the
physicists who want to start
messing with the degree distributions
but now is now is the time for the
engineers now is the time for the
applications and I think you know we
have the potential to really make a
difference here I mean this could be
extremely high impact work and so I
think it's an exciting it's exciting
space to play in and I'm playing in it
with with a variety of people and I'm
welcome to to continue to add to this
list if other people are interested so
with that I'll open it up for questions
thanks
should give up my cell phone number of
the people out the video land you can
call me on my cell phone questions
styx receive ecer land here yeah yeah
it's me to get a campus data real-time
always getting past getting real-time
data is possible but I haven't I haven't
tried mean to get to justify getting
real-time data we'd have to do kind of
we'd have to propose something like what
Eric was talking about earlier about
interventions at the moment I like I
can't make the case that i have any
intervention or even the ability to
detect something that that you know the
operator or the government would care
about but but when we do like there's no
technical reason why that's impossible
like we should and that would be the
ultimate goal would be build a little
filter on the real-time CDR to start
flagging regions that look like they
might have just had a disease outbreak
eat a little bit at face
and uh
bulk up uploads
yeah yeah so are you going to take the
same or does it apply to other ways
communication like eric said msn
messenger facebook messages on Twitter
exchanges because that's a real-time
field that's open and you can just grab
data are there because a lot of these
models should be applicable regardless
to the mode of communication that is
relationships in every care yeah you
should be able to date something in one
can see how it applies to the other one
yeah you have to do something that I'd
like to I mean I have to be honest like
I've got more data that I'm drowning in
data and and and I you know earlier in
my life I was a day to junkie like i
like it just was there's there's never
enough data I always wanted more and I'm
kind of reconsidering that position and
I'm really trying to be kind of more
focused on on questions that you want to
address rather than just trying to
trying to build the biggest social
network that has ever existed we're at
but you know that question appeals to me
as well so yeah i mean i'd love to i'd
love to be able to a couple different
types of data sets together especially
if you can legitimately couple them you
know that you know the hashed idea the
phone number you know the hashed idea of
the the messenger account you know the
hashed idea of the bank account I mean
like so you know this is I'm
collaborating with people who have a
bunch of Bank of America data and so but
there's there's a lot of privacy
implications obviously associated with
with you know coupling these these
different data sets so he mayor's I said
step out for a minute Sonny and mrs.
Marko wait you said that you started
working with Kenya
as well some of their bubble shows
though right so are you seeing sort of
the same kinds of relationships with
call structures no no no are you getting
data within paisa I'm just curious about
sort of their symmetry or similarity in
the networks between the call structure
stuff and the him banking kind of
relationships are you getting what like
this is this is early stages like i
would be i mean i can tell you kind of
what things like the district the degree
distribution looks like for these
different networks and and and it also
the air time sharing i mean there's kind
of a lot of diff there's SMS there's
communication there's air time and
there's imp asa and as you as you go
down that line you get a sparse from
sparser graph and and typically it seems
to be correlated with with volume so if
you if there's a lot of volume between a
dyad you're much more likely to have
that in pace of transaction but we're on
early stages and I really can't I'm not
comfortable saying more than that until
until we really kind of stare at the
data more we have recorded wind change
in terms of
mass intervention like a providing
people with access to information about
it
in the web or phone you know and try to
pose you who that would be the hope I
mean the first thing is like trying to
establish a piece of information that
that would be relevant to these
individuals and I think something like
the fact that there's you know a
potential disease outbreak would be it
would be a pretty good one the other
intervention which is which is less of
an experiment and more of a commercial
entities this idea of inquiry improving
people's socioeconomic status by by
providing them work so giving them
income based on on on them doing these
tasks and then seeing how that changes
their behavior over time and I mean
that's that's nice because that really
done we've got the 15 million people in
East Africa participating that so that's
that's about as big of an intervention
as i can i can imagine what sort of
restrictions do you have to work under
with your working with this data sets i
mean do you have to go to these
locations and work in the applications
you cannot take them well that's that is
taking the data out is generally ok
under major constraints but typically i
mean a lot of this data I've spent weeks
literally weeks in underground basements
in Kigali in Nairobi and it's it's a
surreal experience actually you're in
this giant server farm that's just
because you're on the equator and you're
being blasted by air conditioning and
you you you you take like you know the
elevator up and you walk out the door
and you're the middle of Africa but yet
I mean to deal with that like to give
access to this data I have to work very
intimately with the operators I mean I
and and the operators are interested
because you know we're providing them
services like text eagle and then also
insight into the dynamics of their
subscriber base and at the end of the
day they don't have the computational
resources nor the human resources to
analyze this type of data and and so
that's that's kind of the value
proposition there and so we can I can
take it out I have to it asked for
obvious reasons be encrypted the there
can't be any phone numbers anything that
can identify an individual and I want
that for my own protection as well as as
for the privacy protection I don't like
the last thing I want is to be indicted
and have this data have you know come
out and be going into a court case or
something so it needs to be d
identified in a very rigorous way and
some operators are more are more aware
and paranoid about that than other
operators but for me that's that's kind
of a mandatory thing the taking of the
phone numbers is one thing but you a lot
of information even if you can again it
like Pearson was fun too but clearly you
can identify yeah easily but with the
type of data you have you can probably
identify a lot of these people even
without the phone number that's possible
I I mean like I hope not I I have to
make the case to the IRB that that's not
possible but I think that's like you
know Abby that's I don't know proving
that it is possible yeah I like this is
like a me so we're talking at lunch the
Kleinberg paper of showing out just
looking at topology alone you can you
can start cracking some of this stuff
I'm to be honest I'm less worried about
those tax because those type of attacks
they let you find yourself and maybe you
know figure out what who's who your
friends are friends with but it doesn't
go beyond that so my real concern is
making sure that like and this goes to
the fact of just being able to I mean
ideally I'd like to release some of this
data to the academic community I mean
that's the biggest contribution of my
PhD was not these little generative
models of MIT behavior but rather it was
releasing that data set online and it's
generated literally hundreds of journal
publications as bedell thousands of
times has been a it's been a pretty big
contribution like you having having this
type of data getting it out there in a
way that's ethical would what I think be
a phenomenal contribution but the
problem is trying to figure out a way to
do that while pursuing privacy and and
at the moment I haven't I don't know the
right answer to do how to do it volume
in terms of terabytes you give
just datasets here the large datasets I
mean this thing's compressed
phenomenally well but uncompressed we're
talking by behalf of petabyte
thanks very much